I'm still on the left ?
Ah ha ha.
When do I have 1 joker?
No? Uh,
the answer is yes.
Hull 28 is a success.
No,
the European Union is a success.
Yes,
Emmanuel Macron is the best
President of the 5th Republic.
Yes,
if I have to say something politically correct,
I would say yes.
Yes, there is discussion.
Ha ha ha.
Farmers are right to revolt.
Uh, yes,
It depends against what.
We must tax the ultra-rich.
Yes,
immigration law is good law.
No,
Brussels has too much influence on France,
no,
ecotherorism is a reality.
No,
technological innovation
can solve the climate crisis.
Yes, in part,
we need to increase our aid to Ukraine.
Yes,
Jordan Bordeaux will win the European elections.
What does it mean to win?
But also,
I believe the polls,
yes,
the green dill is not ambitious enough.
No,
Pascal confident
at the head of the list of the commercial majority
in the European elections?
Most likely not.